i'm having to do physio because i've
lost
kind of i've still lost a lot of
movement
and i can't walk without as in the frame
kovid has devastated the life
of 34 year old graham horsefall he's
been in hospital
since january away from his family and
unable to work they told me basically
they were gonna have to
sedate me and put me on a ventilator and
i just kind of went into a bit of blind
panic and
the last thing i remember doing is just
transferring
my wife money just in case something did
happen to me
graham says he's living proof removing
restrictions
can't be rushed why should we be more
cautious about it now
to make sure there's not people that are
going to be suffering
for years to come having to recover
themselves again
having to possibly live off the state
because
they can't work now
vaccination is breaking the link between
infection
and hospitalization and it's now on
offer
to those under 30. from tomorrow morning
we will open up vaccination to people
aged
25 to 29. over the remainder of this
week
the nhs will send texts to people in
these
age groups and of course gps
will be inviting people on their list to
come forward
the government wants every adult offered
a vaccine by the end of next month
secondary school children could come
next with teenage infections
rising fast
this west london classrooms not for
lessons but
surge testing the process looks the same
with the students but the results are
then analyzed by a lab so they're
collected by hanslow
and analyzed and just allows the public
health team
to identify what strains are you know
transmitting in the area which
is really important obviously from
thinking about a public health
perspective
this area and others have rising cases
of the new delta variant
surge testing and vaccines can hold the
spread
but it's tight and that's why some are
calling for caution
i'm very reluctant to say that we should
not
go out of lockdown on the 21st of june
but i think the figures
are in now and it would be wise for the
government
to announce right away a delay
in opening just so that we can all plan
for the post 21st of june period
but a delay would be a hard sell to many
no decisions yet while data is analyzed
and we'll know in a week whether our
lives in lockdown are over
laura bundock sky news